hi youtube my name is Tamara chambers
and I'm Cody Belcher and this is Tamara
Jessa and Cody also just saw two as well
erotically oh let's just say that uh the
Dark Tower wasn't the only tower in that
region uh I think we both went into it a
little like treading lightly um we
there's been some some negative reviews
on this thing and mostly the consensus
is it's just okay I had such a good time
with this bill it was a short action
pass well acted really pretty very
pretty
movie one specific part was incredibly
pretty one aspect of the movie very
pretty
Napoleon isn't the only one who wants to
get stranded on the island of Elba you
know come on huh yeah it was great I
really enjoyed it it was a lot of fun I
hadn't read the dirt tower I never got
around to it
and you have I've read all but the last
book and seven books on theirs right yes
all the others eight all together you
know observer of the name there's comics
though yes and a lot of the only bus on
Amazon a lot of his other books
reference The Dark Tower and kind of
pull from the war and he describes it
and I would have to agree that it is his
best thing to it's his Lord of the Rings
is how he describes it he's a great
writer eyes I really enjoy following him
on Twitter but I like on writing his
book on writing is great I her did you
really get it out yeah but this series
was something that just shocked me how
incredibly fast it drew me in and just
the character of the gunslinger is so
good it's it's a project that you can
see that he has more passionate about
than anything else he's ever done just
with what he brings out of this world
and it's so exciting I went into it
knowing I was going to like it and
regardless of what it was that should be
the new name for this series never shall
like it regardless of what
laughing hi yes that's some big Mario I
did I'm just so excited to see these
characters like brought to life and and
it was weird it was a weird yeah so like
I didn't know so I all I know is the
Dark Tower series is really cool it
looked really interesting from trailers
I loved it is elbow and even
platonically and so I was like I was
ready for it but like but I didn't
realize this it's actually different
from the book yes I thought it was just
going to be an adaptation of the gun the
gunslinger which is the first book right
no it is its own thing
the gunslinger and the kid and and the
man in black those are all characters
from the series but the series is about
him all eight books are about the guns
when you're taking down the Dark Tower
and keeping the dark tower okay that's
like what is the man in black is right
same same kind of deal but but they do
all of it in in this one film and that's
the whole series just happened but but
not not at all they didn't I mean it's
not even like they left things out it's
like it was just a completely different
story
hey weird because like Stephen King so I
well sinkings like infamously like no
you need to do it by the book look at me
he remade the shining wait he thought
Kubrick shining was not good as remade
it himself
yeah some either he's changed or because
unlike Stephen King didn't have control
over this right yeah it's so weird
it also itself it's an hour and a half
it also felt really rushed and what was
given to us was very good I really
enjoyed it but it felt like it was just
a long episode of like a like a Netflix
special well like an American Gods
episode yeah or like even even like a
Jessica Jones like it felt just very
like dark Marvel II good in that sense
which because those are all great in my
opinion but um first Iron Fist anyway
it's not like it felt like just a really
great episode of a Netflix special why
this is Rand Jayant thing and that
people love so much why change it so
much is such an interesting take on it
I didn't have a problem with it you John
I feel like a movie studio that makes
that kind of decision has forgotten the
face and its father and I feel I feel
like that's not good
I don't want to certainly know there's a
great face of your father Joan yeah we
were talking about you writing a book
about the things you yell at people out
of grief arms yeah that would only be
yeah that was only do you think I would
yell at a person how about your father
forgotten the face of your father acting
was crazy good um that kid
I can't wait as he really does yes
career whatever at one point goes like
oh my he's a really good actor but she
said it at a time where he was just
removing things from his wall not like
what about this moment is good well they
may get really good at making us feel
him taking this bull heads off the wall
he just had so much range for kids yeah
this isn't the thing I like Matthew
McConaughey in the most I like I don't
really like Matthew McConaughey that
much calm down
I think I can see you typing already
yeah I think it um I think it's mostly
because I'm from Texas and one of the
things were it's like Oh Matthew
McConaughey like you have me yeah I
really liked him in this like like it
made me retro actively go huh maybe I
should give him another shot that's an
exciting moment when that happens yeah
like he's like my least favorite part of
Amistad he's finding frailty but like he
was good in this yeah I did I mean he
was a really good balance with a
Drizella he really was yeah he's got
that great ability to be like this
powerful creep
what if Jared Leto was not a like a
weird asshole what you know hey like
exactly that's what this was the theater
was a weird there was one moment that's
only weird to me uh which was they go to
this village
the gunslinger says who's your strongest
fear and this woman goes that would be
me and then they they move on and I'm
like no there was a like there would
have been a moment where somebody else
was like like we're like two women would
have gone oh I oh wait what I know
me no permit of is like I've been doing
stand-up comedy for a long time there
would have been some open mic er seer
that would have
laughs oh that's me and everyone's like
shut up Dan it like it it's like in
Janet you've been doing it for two days
okay all no you don't you don't have ten
minutes like no she's from human
dynamics and although only one other
human technically because they're from a
different world or from mid world way
very uh it's very moldable that really
is I mean the world is the same so their
world used to be like way more advanced
because Atlantis kind of thing and then
went back there animals used to talk
right yeah and so they used to have like
this crazy that's why they have the
teleportation portal please a crazy good
technology yeah that's why this weird
village was able to create a generator
okay what I really enjoyed in this
versus the book actually is that the the
boy Jake first of all his last name was
chambers and every time they said Jake
chambers I was like football this day
I'm out right she got away but in the
book it's not focused on that he's such
a great artist and that he like is
really obsessed with his art not
obsessed with his art but later it
wasn't it was a big part of this story
and it was just kind of cooled it like
this badass gunslinger is the hero and
then also like this kid who's like a
sensitive artist expressive art these
are the two hears of this really likes
that I would say if you if you haven't
seen the book well always presented
consumed the book if you haven't seen
the book there they are
alright now I can speak um uh if you
haven't read the books
I'll let used to go that I as someone
who's read most of the books and I know
what happens in the last votes like I
didn't have the book so I just read
spoilers because I was like so many good
and I had to do it I added that um so I
thought it was an odd choice usually
dedicated fan base why'd he do it this
way but now that you did like I liked it
I really enjoyed it and it was um great
action and great characters because I
mean they it already existed but like
it's just weird but I really liked it I
would agree I don't I didn't feel like I
lost anything by not having read the
book laughs and it didn't seem like it
really matters they seem connected and
it wasn't like anything that knocked me
yeah I will say we're more the biggest
writing problem there's a lot of like
expository like we really gotta explain
a lot about this weird world stuff
quickly and so there was a lot of like
information dumping a certain point
where a character would just like
blatantly explain like the history of
something to somebody because they
needed to get that in there okay you can
do that and put it in one movie sciences
why are you can make an hour and a half
now maybe just a half hour yeah a half
hour
Idris Elba running around the bus
yelling at Club Brugge yeah I would want
10 more minutes been talking to that
doctor there was some really great
surprising comedy in this movie what
yeah exciting it was fun and weird now
like this yeah I don't think it's as bad
as people are sitting I feel I think he
said this earlier I think people just
went into it expecting more which I
understand because it just gigantic
mammoth of a series like story wise I
would so much rather watch this and
valerian which I hear is like right
wise yeah like I mean I don't know I
just I think it's I think it's better
than what people are saying so give it
if you're curious it all gave it a
chance right okay so next week I have no
clue it's um Annabelle creations The
Glass Castle nuts up to ninety by nature
why are we going to have to see
Annabelle are we going to have to see
Annabelle are we gonna have to see Adam
Bell should we just see the Dixie Chicks
you maybe see the emoji movie you can't
do this to me we'll see you next week
bye
[Music]